I think a millennia from now,
people are gonna look back
and say,
"Wow, the late 20th century
was really a great time
to be alive on this planet."
Y2K. What does it mean?
SPEAKER: Using two digits
rather than four
made good economic sense.
SPEAKER 2: But when workers
advance clocks to the year 2000?
SPEAKER 3:
The world could meltdown.
Our systems are broken.
We've got a problem
with a couple of digits.
SPEAKER 4:
This has to be solved.
SPEAKER 5: This now looks
like a black hole.
The closer you get to it,
the more it speeds up.
SPEAKER 6: Personal computers
are the least of it.
SPEAKER 7: It's the economies
of the countries
that are interconnected.
This is clearly one of the most
complex challenges in history.
I pray that people don't panic.
I feel like our days
could be numbered.
SPEAKER 8: It's a paranoid
and pathological time.
Lots of weird stuff happens.
SPEAKER 9:
There are people who are
deliberately predicting
the very worst.
NEWS ANCHOR:
Militia groups worry
that the US government
could grab more power.
CROWD: Five...
SPEAKER 10: First, the lights
will go out in Asia.
-CROWD: Four...
-I'm concerned about terrorism.
-CROWD: Three...
-Chaos and confusion.
-CROWD: Two...
-Everything's gonna collapse.
CROWD: One...
There is nothing
I want more right now...
than for the entire world
to be slowed.